U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
has arrived in Beijing for two days of
talks on issues including Regional
security Lincoln says he's seeking to
responsibly manage the relationship with
China he's the highest level U.S
official to visit the country in nearly
five years neither side expects
breakthroughs during the visit with the
world's two largest economies at odds on
a multiple array of issues well ahead of
blinken's visit Chinese foreign Ministry
spokesman Wang Wen bin said that the U.S
needed to respect China's core concerns
including Taiwan former U.S House
speaker Nancy Pelosi's visit to Taiwan
recently escalated tensions with China
culminating in three days of War games
after Taiwanese presidents saying when
visited the U.S earlier this year
the two are also locked in battle over
technology the U.S has imposed sanctions
and Export controls on major Chinese
manufacturing and Technology sectors
Beijing says Washington is stifling
Chinese competition
and of course in recent months the Biden
Administration has moved to shore up
military alliances in the asia-pacific
region including with the other
countries of the Quad Japan India and
Australia
and has expanded base access agreements
with the Philippines China sees these
moves collectively as an effort to
encircle the country and contain it
let's get more on this we can speak to
Brendan O'Connor he's a professor of U.S
politics and Foreign Relations at the
U.S studies Center at the University of
Sydney joins us now from Sydney thank
you for your time it's interesting isn't
it when we look back at how routine U.S
diplomatic visits like this to Chinese
to be I mean Hillary Clinton I believe
visited China seven times during her
four years as Secretary of State it
illustrates how badly relations have
deteriorated haven't they
yes I think it's fair to say relations
are low Point since the opening up of
diplomacy with China in 1978 when Jimmy
Carter was President all U.S presidents
since then have visited China so there's
the prospect of Biden not visiting in
its first four years in power to China
so diplomacy is I think desperately
needed at the moment the visit itself is
a good thing of Anthony blinking but
it's not going to I think four relations
dramatically a lot more has to be done
sort of at different levels of diplomacy
including maybe a president to presence
some at some time maybe at the Apec
Summit in San Francisco and hopefully a
lot more lines of communication being
opened up
would you how how would you say the
Biden Administration has handled its uh
relationship with China especially when
you look at some of the moves I've made
recently uh like the indo-pacific
economic framework which purposely
excludes China and then of course the
military alliances has been making in
the region
well it's a major sea change because
some of the people directing that policy
like Kirk Campbell who is in the Obama
administration had this idea that China
was going to change uh that the U.S was
offering a model which at some point
china would be moving closer towards and
I think they've had to repudiate that
thinking I mean they've done that quite
publicly in the sense of a strategic
rivalry they don't want to use the word
contain China and blinken I think we'll
use that in his statements in Beijing to
say we're not the US isn't containing
China but it very much looks like
containment of China economically
militarily so this is I think in many
regards a continuation of the Trump
Administration policies a very tough one
China policy maybe a degree more of
sophistication of Greater Reliance
certainly on allies than Trump was doing
during his time in office and his
administration but a very tough on China
approach and I think the Chinese have
pushed back on that not wanting to seem
uh at all weak or vulnerable so the
level of rhetoric I think has got to
very unhelpful levels and bringing that
rhetoric down
opening up communication particularly
because of these sort of War games and
Military exercises if an accident was to
occur I think many of us are very
nervous about that and there needs to be
really clear lines of communication to
say to not overreact to any accident in
the air in the in the sort of South
China Sea so that's where this kind of
diplomacy I think can play an important
role well they are meeting now so uh
presumably some of these conversations
are going to happen in the next few days
how useful do you think that's going to
be
well I think it is useful to sort of
tone down the temperature I think the
U.S probably needs to make some
assurances to China that it supports the
status quo on Taiwan uh it benefits no
one for that to be upended I think uh
some sense that it's not against China
growing economically it just has areas
of competition uh and the Chinese and
the Americans I think need to be held by
the International Community by
International organizations by allies
particularly of both sides to some of
their rhetoric both of them talk a lot
about sovereignty a lot about
international law even but no one really
holds them to these rather empty
statements so I think that's the role of
you know International media like your
own organization it's the role of
international organizations to say okay
you're claiming to want cooperation on
the environment you're claiming to want
to believe in sovereignty what about
these breaches of these beliefs and
being held to account of what comes out
of the communiques of these meetings and
the various rhetoric from both sides is
not being done particularly well at the
moment
we've had 31 Chinese entities added to
an export control list this week which
bars them from accessing U.S
Technologies and uh components
how badly does that hurt China how much
of a sticking point is that in the
relations between the two
I think it's a major sticking point I
mean the Chinese are I think pretty
upset about this I mean in the long term
whether it really will slow them down
it's very hard to know whether it will
in fact sort of uh be detrimental to
certain American companies who were
wanting to trade particularly on sort of
uh you know High very high-end computer
technology semiconductors and the like
so there's there's a lot of I think kind
of debate within the economic Community
about how effective these things will be
and a lot of it is to serve domestic
audiences I mean the level of
anti-chinese rhetoric in the U.S
Congress and U.S politics in general is
very high the level of anti-americanism
in Chinese politics is also very high to
kind of in some ways distract from
domestic problems to try to bond
together both countries so that that
rhetoric in the sort of mode of a kind
of booking about new Cold War which I
think is very unhelpful framing leads to
a lot of exaggeration and leads to this
Tit for Tat sanctions and economic
protectionism which you know where this
is where we're at at the moment so I
think you know the role of analysts the
role of the media is to kind of step
back from some of this rare I can say
look it isn't useful to see it as a new
Cold War the Chinese aren't going to go
away like the Soviet Union disappeared
and there's you know some grounds to say
that this economic kind of protectionism
in the end will be detrimental to both
the Americans and the Chinese that it
won't just be a way of slowing down
China as some you know I think in the
United States hope Brendan O'Connor
really interesting to get your
perspective Professor for U.S politics
and Foreign Relations the United States
study center the University of Sydney
thank you
my pleasure